begin recording observations on subject
number 2 named Rebecca sharp or as she
prefers the plebeians sobriquet you
heard me say no milk right because I am
severely lactose intolerant subject was
born in Sarasota Florida
the first indignity in a life full of
unfortunate circumstances definitely not
soy subject lives with a boyfriend we
are going to deal with this correction
subject previously lived with her
boyfriend subjects occupation blackjack
dealer today subjects temperament hey I
don't know man I think you should just
hit what are you hit defeatist oh yeah
great 21
here you go sir congratulations Cheryl
oh thank you
looks like I found my good luck charm me
subject believes no matter what she does
the universe will conspire to punish her
[Music]
or as she writes on a myspace page
I am jinxed
her name's Becky sharp no priors why she
in the database because in the last
three years she's lived in Central City
she's been rear-ended four times her
identity stolen twice a cat burglar
literally burgled her cat right up so
for three lucky lady we meet hazard
seriously that girl's a hazard hazard
that's the one Becky sharp is her name
and she is the a person who her whole
life has had nothing but bad luck so
when she got her powers everything
changed for her overnight and she sort
of takes that to the extreme bad things
happen to people that get in my way
her powers her luck and everybody's bad
luck ripples throughout our other
characters in the show it's like a
series of unfortunate events that
becomes worse and worse and worse and
ultimately is gonna have a massive
impact on on central city that's some
seriously bad luck I know so singers
like meanwhile an episode 403 it's the
return of of Harry wells from earth-2
I thought Jessie now we're having date
night that's what you thought he has a
message for Wally from Jessie quick who
has been living on earth to as the fly
I'll let myself out are you going back
to your earth I'll breach you there
right now right now that's not what I
sound like
there's technology everywhere these days
that's fine we just have one question
for you the particle accelerator
explosion four years ago you were living
in Silicon Valley so if you weren't here
that night
how did you get your powers oh wow oh
you're not gonna believe it it really
was something though
a real life changer and do you two want
to know the best part I wasn't the only
one everybody happy flash day let's
break it down I love that Harrison wells
is coming back from Earth to to call
Cisco on all the dumb things that he
says sometimes he's genuinely funny and
then sometimes he's really cringe
Harrison wells has always balanced that
out so he really cares about them but he
can't stand them half of the time so
there's a new round of the Justice
League ticket giveaway all announced a
new winner at the end of this really the
two sides of this are the twelve
metahumans that the thinker is
collecting they don't necessarily tip
their hat to it and this but the idea
that she was super unlucky up until she
got her powers how did she get her
powers what was the accident that made
that happen that turned her life around
and made her emit this field of luck or
this weird quantum field that allowed
her to control probability so that other
people seemingly had bad luck they would
just exponentially grow I like the way
they make it seem like it spreads like a
virus like it starts in the coffee shop
and just one thing after another just
starts to spread the guy turns the nail
gun right at his face and Barry's just
like oh this is gonna be bad but I
know a lot of you are wondering what's
going on with Jesse quick Harrison wells
as far as I know this is the main
version of Harrison wells we're gonna
get at least for a while we might get a
different version I know we have the
crossover episode and it seems like
there's going to be another version from
Earth X but there's still a lot of big
crossover questions so no confirmation
on that stuff as far as we know Jessie
quick isn't going to be guest starring a
whole lot in the first half of the
season now that's why Harrison wells is
coming this time just to give wall-e the
message yeah no you're not having date
night tonight kids sorry about that
Jessie's probably getting tired of that
long-distance relationship thing and she
probably has some new big problems that
she's trying to tackle the last time we
saw her she was the flash of her three
with Jay Garrick so when they said that
she's been the flash of earth too in
this maybe she just came back to earth-2
at the end of last season because even
though they cleaned up earth two you
have to imagine that just like any
normal planet there'll be more criminals
that will pop up so you'll need another
flash eventually so it's not like it's
gonna stay super peaceful forever you
probably noticed in the flashback
portions of this when Hazzard was still
unlucky she's wearing her comic book
costume there is somebody in present-day
wearing it too but it sounds like she's
using her luck to go back and win a
bunch of money at the casino where she
used to work so that's why she was
wearing that comic book costume just
because that's the uniform for that
casino but I talked a little bit about
her the last time I did a video she's
not necessarily one of your more evil
metahumans she still doesn't like to
kill people she doesn't really want to
hurt people but she is a bit of a
scoundrel and all about using her powers
for her own benefit I think the more
interesting thing though is isn't how
the thinker might try to take advantage
of this power and what that means with
the twelve of them coming together you
have 12 signs of the zodiac it sounds
like maybe it has something to do with
this speed for storm so everybody's
powers will work together in some
interesting way and the thinker just has
some plan that's unfolding but it's a
little too soon to tell and even though
you know there's a lot of funny Harrison
wells moments in this trailer there's no
such thing as luck they did say that he
would be an important part of tonight's
episode in the thinker arc this season
will have something to do with him
trying to find new purpose now that he's
taking care of most of his things going
on on earth to like previously his life
was all about saving Jessie quick so now
he just needs to find something to do
with himself now that that's been
accomplished so even though he just
comes back to give wall-e the message I
think he sticks around because he sees
that they need his help and all these
problems are unfolding with the thinker
so they sort of adopt him again because
Jessie quick doesn't need his help that
much the funny thing about Jessie quick
is the way they set her character up
like she's the super genius because
everybody on earth - is just a little
bit smarter than everybody on earth one
and she's a speedster so if she were to
achieve her potential she'd be more Opie
than most of the speedsters on earth one
save for Barry that just
came back from the speedforce like four
times faster than when he went in I know
there's still a whole bunch of crossover
questions we haven't learned too much
about that they've wrapped filming so
they'll probably be a trailer for that
in the next couple of weeks
Stephen Amell said he still has some
pickups but those are usually like
connective tissue scenes like when he's
just talking to other characters so they
do already have enough footage to cut a
trailer but they're probably just
waiting til we get a little bit closer
usually it's about four weeks out when
they start dropping trailers so that'd
be sometime around next week if you have
any special questions about the flash or
what's going on that you want me to
include in my episode video tonight just
leave them in the comments below
so that'll post after the episode airs
but there is some new Rick and Morty so
if I have time to get that out before
the flash episode I'll try to post that
congratulations to John Isaac you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post my flash episode tonight you can
click here for brand new Justice League
with some Superman Easter eggs and you
can click here for more brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight